In the Philippine city of Angeles, until 1991 it used to be a US air force base
these days, though, many men who are mostly retired
flocked to the city of fallen angeles to make peace and love.
As a result, a whole generation of orphan children has growing up in the Philippines
as through it was a post war country.
Huge numbers of children are fathered by foreign sex tourists
they have never, and in all probability, never will meet their dads.
Sarah charged us $100 for the night.
She's 20, and this is the day that her daughter turns 2 month old
she continues to work in the bar, so she can afford to feed her baby
whose biological father has returned to Australia.
Sarah, is it the first time that the TV crew films you
or like takes you for a night?
The first time we meet Sarah wasn't in a hotel or a bar
but at her home, with visited to film her aunt Nellie.
Nellie has a daughter too, from a Scottish client.
Nellie had to quit sex trade because the bars don't want to hire her anymore.
Youth is the only commodity that is in demand here.
Is this George, father of Michelle?
Wow, she's so small! Sarah!
From my first day in Angeles city
it felt that with the arrive in the modern day Sodom and Gomorrah,
a city where vice is the norm. And that as seems, is the unavoidable future for the children here.
Everywhere we went, we met kids who are clearly been fathered by tourists from all over the world.
We wanted to record as many video letters as we could
messages to all those fathers sitting in their nice homes and comfortable cars,
and thinking about where to invest next.
Jan Lester’s story is so surreal that it’s hard to believe.
His German biological father left him before he was born
and when he was just 2 month old the boy was abandoned by his prostitute mother.
She left the tiny baby to her transgender neighbour and disappeared.
For Jan Lester, Pia instantly became both mother and father.
This is my son Jean-Jean.
Mary-Ann is the Jean-Lester's best friend in neighbor
we soon learnt that she two were fathered by a German sex tourist.
In our school it is frequent.
Their fathers are foreigners,
because their mothers are working in the fields,
and some of them they don't even know their fathers.
Ok, very good.
Her classmates they are teasing her
because she smells bad
sometimes she forgets to wash.
I asked her why she smelled like that
and she said the place where they get water
is very far and their home,
there is no source of water in their house.
For every week she is absent,
like for example in this month
this is the first that she go back to school.
- Mary Ann!
When am working in the bar, I didn't really speak English.
when the guy asks me something like
'What is your name?'
I just say 'yes'.
I only know say 'Yes' and 'No'.
When I am getting 16,
so I decided to starting working at a bar,
so when I make money, so I can help my family.
But when I got pregnant to Mary-Ann. When I knew I was pregnant, so I stopped supporting them.
Jenifer gave birth to Mary Ann after sleeping with a German customer.
A year later, she met a local filipino guy, Aronold.
They aren't married,
but have now lived together for 9 years.
I have a boyfriend, his name is Shawn.
Oh I can't remember, it was a long time ago.
You can take the girl out of a bar,
but you can't take the bar out of a girl.
You know what I mean?
Could you explain it?
Well, you can take a girl out of the bar if you got money
but you can't take the bar out of a girl.
Because they never change. They want the money.
You understand?
You can't trust Filipino woman, you know?
I saw Charlie playing in the street with some other kids.
He wasn't very talkative,
but his appearance gave him away.
Charlie's father's name is Patrick,
an Austrian with Irish roots.
His filipino mother didn't just sell drinks at the local bar.
I looked for Jane in the bar
and then we talk and then go back
and come back and ta-da-da-da.
And then we get married here in the Philippines.
I just love her you know, just lover her smile
and she's very funny.
Then she has very good face, you know.
But for me… I'm happy to be loved again.
Because I didn't love for maybe 2 years
or maybe 3 years.
You know, because my wife when she left me,
I just wanted to f**king kill her.
But I shouldn't say that
but that was my feeling, that's my feeling.
-Hey, Charly!
-Yes, dad.
-Can you bring this girl a sweet?
Bring.
-Thank you very much. Thank you a lot.
2 years ago, Patrick had a stoke
and his young wife suffered the same fate.
Jane is just 34 and for the moment,
she can neither speak nor walk.
Despite everything though, she can still be seen
as one of the lucky ones.
Her husband kept his promise to be true to her in good times and in bad, in sickness and in health.
One of the legs is ok, but the other one is not. Really.
It's not good at the moment,
but she will get better.
This is the plan, we got married 14 years ago.
At then, I was very fat.
I was 120 kilos.
I was f*****g big, really big.
My f*****g face was it was f*****g like that.
And here it was like that.
- Patrick, how old Jen was then?
-She was 18 years old.
Many girls they have to go
to the bar, because they have to eat.
What's going on?
You wanna eat?
Ah?
What should we do today?
Apart from Charlie,  Patrick and Jane
have 2 more children,
they're both grown-up.
Jane had one of them she she was just 16 and working as a prostitute.
It would be stretched to say that their lives resemble a hollywood story,
but all local bar girls dream of a happy ending just like in the movie "Pretty Woman".
The nurse will come tomorrow, Jane.
The nurse will come here tomorrow.
Five o'clock.